the Resident Evil 4 chainsaw demo is a
spooky Taste of what's to come when the
full survival horror experience arrives
on PC and console next week on March
24th the demo is fairly short but
luckily it's hiding some secrets for you
to uncover called mad chainsaw mode it
makes the game substantially more
challenging and isn't for the faint of
heart last week it was assumed that the
mode was limited to luck but now there
is an easier way to unlock it all you
need to do is highlight main game hold
L1 and R1 press up left down right
square triangle Circle X X or translate
that to Xbox if you'd like the re4 demo
is also hiding some extra Firepower in
its infested Village there are two
weapons to grab in this demo each one
being a marked improvement on Leon's
regular Firearms here's where you can
find both of them the shotgun is the
easiest if you don't mind running
through a horde of bloodthirsty
villagers just pass the bonfire to the
left you'll spot a house with an open
door either hop over the fence or run
straight through the entrance run up the
stairs and you'll see a shotgun in the
display case like most video game
shotguns this weapon is devastating at
close range it only has a handful of
shells though so you'll want to make
every shot count when using it you can
also find a hand grenade in the display
case next to it as for the other secret
weapon in the demo you're going to want
to travel light after you escape the
first hunt and then deal with some
villagers along the path you'll come
across the gate to the Village but don't
go in just yet first open your inventory
and empty everything that Leon is
carrying with nothing but clothes on
your back guide Leon into the village
wait for the right moment and follow the
path on the right turn left at the top
of the path and enter the open well if
you have any items on you the well is
going to be locked and inaccessible
inside this area you'll find a chest
that contains the TMP and plenty of ammo
to help you fight against the infected
Village the TMP is easily the best
weapon in the demo as it has a high rate
of fire is extremely stable and
surprisingly precise maybe both of these
secret weapons are exactly what you need
to make it through the Mad chainsaw mode
alive if you've played that difficulty
mode hit the comments below and post
your time of completion don't lie we'll
know
thank you